another study has come out I'm sure they
spent a lot of money on this with great
insight that says people don't save
enough to retire on Wow oh you're
kidding really I thought everyone had
millions of dollars in their 401k you
mean people don't save money you're
kidding me I mean most people walk
around I'm gonna buy this and put it on
payments I'm gonna buy that and put it
on payments I'm not saving anything in
my 401 K I can't spell Roth IRA they
spend everything they make with this
great idea that they're going to retire
and count on the government which is
well known for its ability to handle
money to take care of them dude what's
going to end up happening is you're
going to be so broke you can't pay
attention
I mean minimum wage will be giving you a
raise I mean you're gonna be so bad
you're gonna be ordering the cookbook 72
ways to prepare Alpo and love it you
know it's a funny joke in a way but in a
way it's not I literally had a friend of
mine not long ago who went to visit his
aunt he hadn't seen her in a while and
she was in her 70s she wasn't in really
good health in the home as a paid for
home if it was a modest home and it was
really clean and nice and had been kept
up well and he went to make lunch and he
opened up the cabinet and it was full of
dog food
and she didn't have a dog that scares
crap out of me
because I do not want to be working at
McDonald's when I'm 78 unless it's the
one I own in st. Thomas I just don't
want to live like that and you know
there's only one way that you don't
retire broke you have to save money
though so I get the big money right
there in sight in sights like that you
know it really doesn't matter the
quality of your investment or how smart
you are or how sophisticated you are if
you don't put any freaking money in the
account so USA Today is got this story
out 36 percent this study says
front page of the money section USA
Today about 36% of workers have less
than $1,000 been there done that
when it comes to retirement savings 36%
little over one-third of Americans have
less than $1,000 in savings that's
financial suicide it's not going to go
well for you at retirement here's what's
really scary only 22% have more than
$100,000 now I got to tell you if you
stock a hundred thousand bucks on the
corner this table I'll smile and take it
okay that's a lot of money but when you
get to retirement it's not because if
you're living on 8% that's eight
thousand dollars a year living on ten
percent that's ten thousand dollars a
year it's 800 bucks a month we're back
to dog food again people and that's
$100,000 saved and that's only 100
thousand and above is only 22% of
Americans well you can't save money out
there yeah you can't save money cuz you
freaking spend it all that's why you
can't say money can't say money cuz
you'll have a plan you can't save money
because you don't care you're more
worried about the big screen I'm gonna
have an 80-inch because my 70-inch is
just not cutting it and so I have
nothing in my retirement zip zero a
survey finding said that debt is
weighing heavily on many people oh say
more surveys man I'm glad they got this
thing because none of us knew that debt
is weighing heavily on many people with
58 percent of workers and 44 percent of
retirees saying they have a problem with
their level of debt yeah like workers
many retirees are also short on funds
with 58% having less than $25,000 in
savings and investments about 60 percent
of people at less than 25,000 65 percent
of workers plan to work at retirement
I'll bet here's what's interesting 65
percent of workers plan to work at
retirement and yet like 75 percent have
almost nothing saved so the other 10%
are oh they just don't have a clue at
all that's what that means
so many people realize they're not on
track in saving for retirement and the
two most important reasons they give or
not saving is the cost of living and
day-to-day expenses you know what cost
of living is not your problem and your
day-to-day expenses aren't your problem
it's your spending you have a car you
can't afford you're going on vacations
you can't afford you're buying clothes
you can't afford you had Christmas that
rich people didn't have you're spending
like you're in freaking Congress that's
why you have no money now if you're on a
budget and you're not getting out of
debt I'm not talking to you but I mean
when you say 36 percent of Americans
one-third of Americans have literally no
clue how they're going to eat when
they're not able to work because old age
sneaks up on them does that not scare
you out of your mind societally speaking
well we ought to take care of the poor
yeah we ought to take care of the poor
here's an idea though if you're poor
maybe I'll save some money so you're not
anymore well it's easier said than done
yeah I know it's what I've been teaching
people for 25 years on this radio show
get on a written plan live on less than
you make set aside an emergency fund cut
up your stupid credit cards you know
here's what's hilarious the 36 percent
of Americans that have less than $1,000
in the bank if you sat down had lunch
with them I'll bet you they say I'm
using my credit card so I can get points
to travel my airline miles are important
to me they've got a better plan to beat
the credit card company than they do to
save for their own retirement because
they bought the lie the debt is a way of
life so when you don't have any payments
when you get rid of the car payment when
you get rid of student loan that's been
around so long you think it's a pet you
get rid of American distress you get rid
of I discovered bondage you get rid of
ever all this crap where you're paying
payments out all the time and you look
up you'll have money and here's the
other thing when you start living on a
plan you're going to realize you've been
spending more than you make you're
spending money you don't have to buy
things you don't need to impress people
you don't really like stop it stop it
you've
not to freaking get in control this is
called growing up America it's an
indication of maturity when you save
money one definition of maturity
emotional spiritual maturity is the
ability to delay pleasure and we've got
apparently a large segment of our
culture there are a bunch of children
walking around in adult bodies because
they have no ability to delay pleasure
whatsoever and you're going to become a
major problem for the rest of us oh you
already are maybe it's time you started
getting on a budget and selling spin you
need to amputate your freakin toe
it's time to get the credit cards out
and chop them up it's time to get on a
written plan America this just scares
the crud out of me from a society
standpoint 36 percent of America is the
only member thousand dollars you got
some work to do boys and girls need to
learn how to spell 401k real soon this
is the Dave Ramsey show
you